hey everyone i am nikunj a Givenchy I
work in the Interactive Media Group and
I'm gonna tell you a bit about Project
triton which is about sound propagation
in virtual reality games and augmented
reality so the roots of this project
actually go back to my grad school days
and I worked in a group that was all
about physical simulation and UNC Chapel
Hill and I got interested in audio
because it seems like a very cool
problem to work on at the time and one
of the attractions for me to come to MSR
back like a decade ago was we have Xbox
and I used to think well I used to dream
that this sort of thing if this would be
a great fit and if it could be used in
games one day and now it's actually
shipping in games so it's sort of a
thing that makes MSR very special that
you can do this sort of research a
product transition over here so the
purpose of this technology is stated
simply is to make sounds respect the 3d
environment like we have great lighting
technology in games you can move the Sun
wherever you want and things look like
they should leave you have all this cool
technology this project is about making
sound do something similar and the
applications are pretty broad I
mentioned games but there's mixed
reality of course where the spatial
audio sense is important to complement
visuals and then there's architectural
design more and more when you're
building spaces these days you worry
about how is this gonna sound once it's
built the research problem is that 3d
acoustic simulation is extremely
expensive if you try to do this on a
computer in real time it's off by at
least a factor of a million so doing
what we're doing and hoping that
machines will get fast doesn't really
cut it for this so our solution was that
we have to cheat somebody gives us a
scene we take it on a computer cluster
we do all the analysis we want to do on
it and then we already know the results
that we would have computed in real time
so all that remains is to just apply the
effects in real time so let me just show
you some examples so this is an example
from Gears of War for
so if you thought nothing happened
that's a good thing so what this demo is
trying to show you is the loudness on
that rain is varying naturally as you
walk through the scene you have a broken
roof the rain gets louder you are
enclosed in some space the rain gets
lower in volume before frightened what
had to be done for this is an audio
designer would have to go in and say
yeah the roof is broken here I need to
bring this volume up by this amount in
that location and by the time the person
walks to that location I have some
logical trigger that lowers the volume
and so on and so forth and you can
imagine this for the little section of a
scene these scenes are square kilometers
nobody can go and do that in detail
everywhere so designers had to say ok
like hope for the best I have this much
time let me do the best I can with this
now the job of the audio designer shifts
to physics will do its thing first
that's my baseline and then when I want
to do my art is on top of that right so
we're taking the drunk work out of it
and letting them focus their time on the
things that matter for games here's
another example this one is showing
there's only one source some water drops
and it's showing you you're inside a
cave and how the sounds reverberation
and loudness is changing as you walk
around
[Music]
so as you get further away from the
raindrops the sound gets more echoey
like it expect then you're walking
around the wall and the sound just drops
in loudness now this scene already
represents a problem with simple
techniques like one of the standard
techniques is you take the line of the
straight-line distance from the source
and listener and say as that increases
the sound should become fainter that's
distance attenuation but at the end of
this video you're actually really close
to the source in a line-of-sight sense
but what you want is the waves to wrap
around that wall and to capture those
effects to get the right sort of
loudness again these things are pretty
mundane for us right but when you try to
model them in 3d scenes they actually
turn out to be really complex so
internally just to give you a flavor of
this this is what's going on inside so
I'm showing you a top view like a slice
through a 3d volumetric simulation so
what Righton does is when you give it a
3d scene it will place lots of these
probes think of standing inside the
scene and clapping right that's an
impulse and then it models how this
impulse propagates through the scene so
you can see these wave fronts go around
all these obstructions in its way to get
to point A
that's diffraction that's what makes
sound simulation different from light
and difficult and if you put two
microphones at point a and B you'd get
two different signals on the right so
those signals that you get from an
impulse is called an impulse response
and the point being that the acoustic
set point a and point B are really
different if those two spots will sound
very different and the simple response
captures that fact it captures how the
scene modified this sound as it went
from the source to the listener inside
the Cathedral or outside that space and
to give you a flavor of the idea it is
don't store all this information that's
petabytes of information we can't keep
that around so what we do is we look at
these impulse responses and we build
algorithm say
what would the ear extract out of this
there's a whole amount of literature on
psycho acoustics and we're taking
lessons from that and saying okay what
are the important aspects of these
impulse responses that we should keep
and then we you throw out the details
that you won't
hopefully can't listen to so that's it
for me that gives you an idea and those
are the two lengths for the research
behind this you can also find papers
there and then also the product that
ships with this technology that's the
second link here thank you
[Applause]
you